this is the Michael Noel's show I'm not
Michael Knowles I'm Ted Cruz and it's
1:30 in the morning senator just because
you're the number one podcaster in
America does not mean that you can also
take my show well enjoy your show and
thanks to everyone who Tunes in alright
I'll see you back here later tonight
you'll go do your real job
[Music]
you know I don't show up to the Senate
and start casting votes but senator Cruz
will be heading over to the Capitol and
this will be the final day of
impeachment he's gonna cast that final
vote on whether to acquit the president
or to remove him from office that will
all be very exciting we will talk about
it later on on verdict with Ted Cruz
before then though we have got to talk
about much happier news the State of the
Union the State of the Union which is
usually a boring terrible speech was
magnificent
president Trump gave and I think I am
not exaggerating when I say this the
greatest State of the Union address in
American history it was wonderful for
three distinct reasons first of all the
stories that he told he is a master
showman so it's not surprising that he's
able to tell really good stories Ronald
Reagan did this very well too you saw
this with moments with Rush Limbaugh
moments with a number of really
beautiful moments the second reason it
was so great is that the Democrats
reacted like monsters I mean you
couldn't have scripted more villainous
reactions that they couldn't applaud for
low unemployment they couldn't applaud
for it for anything anything that Trump
said they had to oppose and then the
third reason that the State of the Union
speech was so good I think it was truly
the best in history is because it was
true the State of the Union actually is
strong the State of the Union has never
been stronger in my lifetime I mean I've
never watched the State of the Union
while the country was doing this well
and there there was a really no
substitute for the truth so let's let's
jump right into it the the Democrat I
think the biggest conclusion the biggest
takeaway is the Democrats couldn't clap
for anything just an example president
Trump running down the list low
unemployment low black unemployment low
disabled unemployment low female
unemployment watch the reaction listen
the unemployment rate for
african-americans Hispanic Americans and
Asian Americans has reached the lowest
levels in history
african-american youth unemployment has
reached an all-time low
african-american poverty has declined to
the lowest rate ever recorded the
unemployment rate for women reached the
lowest level in almost 70 years and last
year women filled 72 percent of all new
jobs added we have to stop it right
there because you can see in the house
there are these female Congress women on
the Democratic side wearing all white
and the the white is a symbol of the
suffragettes and female activism and
women getting the right to vote and
those women who are ostensibly standing
up for women's rights when the president
says that we've got record number of
women in the work force they sit there
frowning angry all upset now for me I
usually don't tout the female
unemployment rate because the female
unemployment rate is a different rate
than say different racial unemployment
rates or even age groups because it it
doesn't take into account women who
choose to stay at home so I mean if you
have a perfectly low female unemployment
rate than what you're basically saying
is women are not able to stay at home
and raise their families and be stay at
home wives and I don't think we want to
live in a country where women are not
allowed to raise their children so it's
a little bit different but those female
Democratic Congress women they're all
for it right that's what they're
standing up for except they can't stand
up they've got to sit down because
Donald Trump is actually the guy who
accomplished the things that they say
that they want to accomplish but it goes
on he keeps listing all of these
achievements particularly economic
achievements and they just can't smile
they just can't clap the veterans
unemployment rate dropped to a record
low
the unemployment rate for disabled
Americans has reached an all-time low
workers without a high school diploma
have achieved the lowest unemployment
rate recorded in US history
a record number of young Americans are
now employed there it is anything I mean
he could say that everybody is gonna get
fifty million dollars for free and the
Republicans will stand up and the
Democrats are sitting down because
there's always partisan ranker there
obviously people will sit down when they
disagree on some policy position but
this takes it a step further than we've
seen in the past this is truly an
example of Democrats refusing to applaud
any of the president's accomplishments
it plays very badly on television it
really makes them look anti-american
which in many cases unfortunately they
are then President Trump takes this
tactic of getting the Democrats to
expose who they are to expose that
they're not really rooting for America
he takes this into the realm of pro life
so he tells this story of a little girl
who was able to survive she was born
very early and now she's a healthy child
and he says that he's now calling on
Congress to finally ban the barbaric
practice of late term abortion not first
trimester abortion not the morning-after
pill not all the areas where Democrats
and pro-abortion people want to argue
the the pro-life point he's talking
about the very end stages when the baby
looks just like a baby and moves like a
baby and everybody more or less agrees
that that's barbaric and they won't
stand for that either Ella reminds us
that every child is a miracle of life
and thanks to modern medical wonders 50%
of very premature babies delivered at
the hospital where Elly was born now
survived it's an incredible thing thank
you very much
our goal should be to ensure that every
baby has the best chance to thrive and
grow just like Ellie that is why I'm
asking Congress to provide an additional
50 million dollars to fund neonatal
research for America's youngest patients
that is why I'm also calling upon
members of Congress here tonight to pass
legislation finally banning the late
term abortion of babies this is really
an important point because for so long
tactically pro-lifers in the right lose
the abortion argument because the
pro-abortion people say oh come on a
zygote is not a baby
a an embryo is not a baby a fetus is not
a baby it's a little clump of cells it
looks nothing like a baby and tactically
it's much wiser for pro-lifers to argue
at the later stages of pregnancy where
you've got the vast vast majority of
Americans opposing abortion and
President Trump got the Democrats to
reveal the logical conclusion of their
abortion advocacy because they're not
just talking about babies who were one
or two weeks old they are talking about
babies who are seven months old eight
months old nine months old in the case
of the governor of Virginia he said that
the baby could be born and then maybe
they'd killed the baby after he was born
in the case of the Democratic governor
of New York and equal mo changed the
penal law in New York with his abortion
law so that you can kill a baby up until
the moment of birth and if you kill a
pregnant mother you won't be charged
with double homicide just single
homicide Trump got them to expose that
their hatred of Trump has driven them so
crazy that they can't cheer on successes
for all sorts of Americans and they're
actually sitting down in the support of
late term abortion and then as if that
didn't tug on the heartstrings enough
President Trump gets to some really
personal moments we will get to that as
well first I've got to thank our friends
over at movement you know I love
movement watches I love all of movements
project products I have given them to my
family and there
is the biggest hits at holidays well
guess what's coming up guys Valentine's
Day and men in particular not so great
at giving Valentine's gifts I speak from
experience enjoy a stress-free
Valentine's Day with movement's
best-selling styles already pre packaged
together into sleek gift box sets that
your significant other boyfriend or
girlfriend will absolutely love you can
choose between beautiful watches and
jewelry combo boxes they've got
everything for your style I just ordered
the new movement arc automatic which is
their cool automatic watch unfortunately
was delivered to LA and I'm still in DC
so I'm not gonna get it for a couple
days and I can't wait to get it it's
just really sleek really really cool
products get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
movement
MVM t.com slash Knowles canna wles
they got rid of the vowels and they pass
the savings on to you enjoy a free extra
watch strap plus free gift box with
every watch order that's MVM t-dot-com
slash Noel's canna w l es for your most
stress-free valentine's day gifting yet
and it's been one of the most successful
gifts I've ever given to my family
members recommend that you do it as well
president Trump moves from the economic
questions onto this cultural issues
late-term abortion then he gets into
some really personal stuff he gets into
stories about the parents who have
suffered terrible tragedies because of
terrorism gets into American servicemen
who have made big sacrifices I mean
reuniting families during the State of
the Union and then one story that is
particularly important for those of us
in the conservative movement especially
those of us in broadcasting is rush
limbaugh rush limbaugh the peerless
conservative broadcaster the pioneer he
invented conservative talk radio he
remains the best political analyst in
the history of radio he's just there is
no number two there's rush limbaugh and
then a huge gap and then a bunch of
other people below rush limbaugh
announces that he has a late stage
cancer and of the lungs
president Trump immediately invites him
to the State of the Union and rush is
sitting next to the first lady Melania
president Trump gives him a truly
tear-jerking tribute here tonight is a
special man beloved by millions of
Americans who just received a stage for
advanced cancer diagnosis this is not
good news but what is good news is that
he is the greatest fighter and winner
that you will ever meet rush limbaugh
thank you for your decades of tireless
devotion to our country
I am proud to announce tonight that you
will be receiving our country's highest
civilian honor the Presidential Medal of
Freedom
I will now ask the First Lady of the
United States to present you with the
honor please
[Applause]
I dare you to have a dry eye after
listening to that I mean it was so
magnificent first of all God bless Rush
Limbaugh right I'm just so personally
I'm so pleased I so admire the guy I'm
so pleased that he got that kind of
honor but consider it from the
perspective of President Trump very
often there are these personal stories
Ronald Reagan actually kind of invented
this tradition of inviting individuals
from different walks of life and making
their personal stories part of the
broader narrative of the country but as
with everything President Trump does he
just turns it up to 11 so rush gets this
terrible diagnosis late late stage
cancer so he immediately invites Rush
and then he takes it a step further and
announces at the State of the Union that
he's going to give Rush the highest
civilian honor in the country the Medal
of Freedom and Rush looked genuinely
shocked I don't think he saw leaked
reports about that and then Trump takes
it a step further and has the first lady
sitting next to him present the medal at
the State of the Union before a joint
session of Congress it's just incredible
the showmanship first of all and beyond
that the honor the dignity of it oh my
gosh it was just beautiful the State of
the Union addresses are boring they are
chloroformed on television usually until
this presidency Trump all of his State
of the Union addresses have been good
this one was by far the best and the
Democrats could not have been more
furious at least eight House Democrats
boycotted the State of the Union they
were led by aoc and it it was just a bad
look I mean you had you had them sitting
down they couldn't cheer for any of the
great policies but you had Nancy Pelosi
wouldn't stand up for Rush Limbaugh when
the guy is being told he's got this
awful illness probably not going to end
very well just statistically obviously
he's getting this big honor now and
Nancy Pelosi wouldn't applaud wouldn't
stand up House Democrats wouldn't stand
up wouldn't stand up for a number of
these
for a number of these achievements and
then at the beginning of the state of
the union you had Nancy Pelosi break
protocol because usually when they open
up the State of the Union the Speaker of
the House will say I have the honor and
the privilege of announcing the
president of United States Nancy Pelosi
nixed that totally broke from tradition
she just said members of Congress the
president of United States seething
furious and then at the end of the
speech she did something that was so
disgusting the the president hands a
copy of the speech to the vice president
and to the Speaker of the House and at
the end of the speech right when
President Trump said you know our best
days are ahead the best is yet to come
god bless america she stood up and
ripped up the speech which is obviously
offensive to half of the country because
they've she has a different political
point of view then then the president
and so it's offensive she's showing such
disrespect for people who have a
different political point of view but
she's so showing such disrespect for the
office of the president she's saying
such disrespect for the American people
I mean he is their elected
representative right he is their
president and she's ripping it up I was
under the impression she was ripping up
the Constitution but I realized no no it
wasn't that she was actually ripping up
the speech that he had given her I mean
I guess this plays very well to the aoc
crowd this plays very well to a handful
of super woke Millennials and blue
checkmarks on Twitter I don't think this
plays well in Peoria I don't think this
plays well in Wisconsin or Pennsylvania
or any of those battleground states
Michigan that the Democrats are gonna
have to win in 2020 and it's being
played out in the polling president
Trump's polling has never been better
not just according to right-wing poll
firms also according to Gallup polling
which isn't particularly favorable to
Trump and the Democrats polling couldn't
be worse and they really blew it tonight
I mean they had a chance to move past
impeachment president from so smart did
not bring up impeachment didn't bring it
up even once because watching this
speech tonight you realize that all of
this impeachment which makes up all the
news cycles that's all ever
everybody's talking about that's gonna
be a punchline in history that is not
going to be what historians talk about
it's gonna be a shame for the Democratic
Party a low point in a punchline what
what historians are gonna talk about or
all the things that were mentioned in
the State of the Union he was very wise
to leave it out and if Democrats don't
get beyond this angry frowning cross
your arms they're certainly not going to
do well in November and and we've we're
seeing that in the numbers we're seeing
that in Iowa we will get to the debacle
in Iowa in just a second we will get to
the imminent collapse of the Biden
campaign and the surge of Bernie what
that means to because we're seeing two
visions of America we're seeing the
State of the Union vision that the
president gave us and we're seeing the
rising socialist vision of Bernie
Sanders and those two visions could not
be more different but first I got to
tell you about our wonderful friends
ever equipped quip makes it simple to
develop healthy habits starting with an
electric toothbrush refillable floss and
anti cavity toothpaste you need to get
an electric toothbrush I hesitated for
years because I'm a kind of lazy guy
right so I just especially when I was a
teenager I just I basically brush my
teeth with a stick and then one time a
dentist told me you got to get an
electric toothbrush now that's all I use
keeps my teeth pearly white quips
electric brush has sensitive sonic
vibrations with a built-in timer in
30-second pulses to guide a full and
even clean the quip floss dispenser
comes with pre marked string to help you
use just enough so you don't like pull
out the whole thing and you mess it up
that's kind of what I do
Plus quip delivers fresh brush heads
floss toothpaste refills to your door
every three months with free shipping so
your routine is always right and you
don't end up using the same toothbrush
head for like two years at a time not
I'm not saying I do that but a lot of
guys do that join the over three million
people who are using quip today you can
start it for just twenty-five bucks if
you go to get quip dot-com slash Michael
right now you will get your first refill
free that is your first refill free at
get quip dot-com slash Michael GE tqu IP
comm / Michael mi CH AE el quip is the
good habits company it's good to be in
good habits not in bad habits
we saw a lot of bad habits in the
audience at the State of the Union we're
seeing a lot of bad habits on the
campaign trail right now all of that is
voting very well for the president
president is now polling at 49%
according to Gallup poll now you might
say 49% that's not good that's less than
50 true but it's the best that Gallup
has given President Trump at any point
in his presidency and let's not forget
Trump won the election the first time
too he's also beating Barack Obama at
this same stage in his presidency and
don't forget Barack Obama got reelected
it's voting very well for Trump because
he's he's doing the thing all right he's
he's actually delivering results the
real reason that the State of the Union
address was so good is not the Flair
it's the fact that it was true he's
really delivering on results whereas
everything the Democrats are doing is
just about a fictional narrative so
there they have a ton of investigations
about Russian collusion but Russian
collusion wasn't real they are launching
investigations about how he didn't pay
his taxes but we know he did pay his
taxes we saw some of his tax returns
they're launching investigations about a
quid pro quo impeachable offense in the
Ukraine that didn't happen all right
it's all just imaginary nonsense
actually bringing it back to rush
limbaugh and rush limbaugh at this
beautiful moment in his announcement
that he has this illness and he said i
don't like to talk about myself and he
really doesn't he tells some jokes about
you know he's got talent on loan from
God but the reason his show is so good
he's talking about the things that
matter to people he respects his
audience and he's really giving them
some value that's what the Trump
administration is doing not just in the
State of the Union but in the Union
generally the Democrats are not doing
that and it shows in the polling so
Trump doing very well in the polling
Democrats collapsing they can't even
conduct their own election the first
state that's voting in the Democratic
presidential primary we still don't have
the results as of this taping we've got
62% of the results in and they're pretty
dodgy results and I think everybody is
pretty dismayed about this you know what
we were told going into the 2020 Iowa
caucuses is the Democrats are fired up
they can't wait to kick out Trump
they're so excited about this
candidates actually the turnout was just
as low as it was in 2016 that doesn't
even account for population growth in
Iowa it was pretty low and we still
don't have the results the results we
have right now popular vote this is the
popular mode this is not going to decide
who wins the state which would be
decided by Delegates this is the popular
vote first place Bernie Sanders second
place mayor cheat but I'm sorry mayor
Pete Buda judge third place Elizabeth
Warren fourth place Joe Biden a pitiful
a pitiful result for former Vice
President Biden fifth place Amy
Klobuchar that's a popular vote in term
of the delegate counts Pete Budaj is in
first place he didn't win the most votes
but somehow he's winning in the delegate
count
second place Bernie then Warren Biden
and Amy that's with 62% in this a little
strange because Pete moody judge when
zero percent of the vote was in declared
himself the winner in Iowa is really
strange too because the app that was
used to report the results was produced
by an ominously named company called
shadow incorporated which received a
large infusion of cash from the Peabody
Judge campaign very strange because the
Democratic Party establishment has tried
again and again to steal the nomination
from Bernie Sanders I don't like Bernie
Sanders I don't like anything that he
stands for I think that his ideology is
wicked and anti-american we'll get to
that in a second
but you got to call a spade a spade the
guy is getting robbed he got robbed in
2016 and it looks like there might be
some shenanigans in play again
regardless of what happened in Iowa
Bernie and Budaj edge are in a dead heat
again it's a little weird because going
into the Iowa caucuses the polls showed
Bernie surging Bulls showed Bernie with
a lead outside the margin of error
internal polling seemed to show Bernie
with a big lead then all of a sudden
Budaj edge swoops in and declares
victory very odd now compare budda
judges reaction which was all bravado
right he just says we are going on to
New Hampshire victorious no evidence of
that whatsoever he said tonight an
impossible hope became an undeniable
reality which is a meaningless statement
the only meaning you could pull from
that is that it's undeniable that Pete
Buddha judge one Iowa and that was very
deniable because zero percent of the
votes were in at the time compare that
reaction to the Iowa caucuses to Bernie
Sanders his reaction he was asked are
you going to declare victory and he said
no I'm going to wait until the votes
come in what's your reaction sir to
Mayor Buddha judge last night declaring
victory I don't know how anybody
declares victory before you have an
official statement results so we're not
declaring victory
but what we are saying is that at a time
when the people of Iowa people of
America really want to know what the
results is when they want to see some
transparency and when the Iowa
Democratic Party is not providing that
the time they met up we thought is
inappropriate the results that response
from Bernie Sanders is the response of a
guy who's confident that he's got the
people behind him
Pete Budaj edges response was the
response of a guy who's trying to pull a
fast one
by Bernie rather had some real
confidence there and I think he's got
that confidence because regardless of
what happens with the Iowa tally if we
ever get the final vote tally he's he's
got a lot of momentum going into New
Hampshire same cannot be said of Joe
Biden absolute campaign collapse even if
Joe Biden wasn't going to win Iowa and
really should have won Iowa because Joe
Biden's entire campaign pitches that
he's electable particularly electable in
these purple states in the Midwest in
the Rust Belt that are really going to
matter and he lost in one of the states
that he probably should have won and he
didn't lose by a little he lost by a lot
came in fourth place it's hard to see
the argument for his campaign he's not
doing very well in New Hampshire
maybe he'll be okay in Nevada and he's
he's losing even his lead in South
Carolina which was the big firewall
probably the the Biden campaign is
finished there was a pro Biden political
action committee that is now planning on
spending $900,000 in New Hampshire to
boost the campaign probably not going
anywhere it's probably too late so it
looks like right now the momentum
remains with Bernie and then you'll get
a boot a judge or a Bloomberg trying to
fill the moderate lane that Biden is
quickly losing so it's coming down to
Bernie this gives us two visions for
America
you got the vision of growth of
flourishing of making America great
again that you got from President Trump
I mean at one point in Trump State of
the Union he actually used the phrase
manifest destiny to refer to our
exploration of outer space our
exploration of Mars when he set out her
when he already said rather manifest
destiny I just I wanted him to go full
king charles ii dissolve pelosi
Congress he'll be king until maybe I
didn't want to go quite that far but I
really felt great about it that's a
that's a thriving flourishing vision of
America you got that on one hand and
you've got Bernie style communism on the
other hand I don't use communism lightly
Bernie Sanders actually has defended
communist regimes for his whole freakin
career the man honeymooned in the Soviet
Union that's all true just a quick
little rundown of the of Bernie's record
on communism Bernie Sanders defends
breadlines
you know 20 sometimes American
journalists talk about how bad the
country is because people are lining up
the food that's a good thing in other
countries people don't line up for food
the rich get the food and the poor spark
to death bread lines are a good thing
that's good Bernie 2020 bread lines are
a good thing Bernie defends Fidel Castro
but I remember for some reason of being
very excited when when Fidel Castro made
the revolution in Cuba and I was a kid
and I remember reading that and it was
just seemed right inappropriate that
poor people were rising up against
rather ugly rich people and I remember
again very distinctly a very distinct
feeling I was watching the debates you
remember the famous Nixon Kennedy
debates that was the first time in the
presidential camp candidates actually
debated actually you know there when you
read novels people say there's a sick
feeling in you something usually I'm
sufficiently unemotional not to be sick
but actually got up in the room and
almost left the puke because for the
first time in my adult life what I was
seeing is the Democrats and Republicans
both of them and of course as Rick
points out Kennedy was the flashing
young liberal and what we were seeing
right before my eyes way way back then
and I didn't know anything about
politics but clearly that there really
wasn't a whole lot of difference between
the two he wanted to puke because people
were criticizing one of the worst commie
thugs in history Fidel Castro Bernie
defends other horrible regimes we'll get
to that in a second when we'll get to
the way to really make the argument here
not just the argument for how great
America is doing under a conservative
vision but the argument for why we must
reject socialism it's not just about
economic
it's about so much more than economics
we'll get to that in a second first
doesn't it just feel like we're halfway
through 2020 it does but the truth is we
haven't even gotten started the election
is just heating up and because we know
that you need to stay up to date we are
giving you 20% off all new memberships
20% off all new memberships when using
promo code DW 2020 members get our
articles add free access to all of our
live broadcasts and show library the
full three hours of the ben shapiro show
select bonus content access to the
mailbag and now election insight op-eds
from ben shapiro plus our all-new access
tier gets you into live online Q&A
discussions with me Ben drew Matt Walsh
and our sites writers and special guests
you ask we answer and the leftist here's
tumblr just goes glug glug glug glug
glug download The Daily wire app a
member exclusive so you can get push
notifications straight to your phone
again that is promo code DW 20 20 20 %
off joined today and stay informed on
all things 2020 daily wire.com we'll be
right back with a lot more
bernie sanders defends breadlines bernie
sanders defends Fidel Castro said he
wanted to puke when American presidents
of both parties were condemning that
awful dictator Bernie Sanders doesn't
just defend Castro he defends communists
in Nicaragua how do you find the
sincerity of sandanista leaders
I was impressed I was impressed by
Father disco dope if he is a very gentle
very loving man of what Tiger is an
impressive guy actually the bread lines
are good actually Fidel Castro is good
actually the Sandinistas are good Bernie
defends the USSR the Soviet Union the
evil empire itself when we were in
Moscow for example were extremely
impressed by their public transportation
system the station's themselves were
absolutely beautiful chandeliers that
were beautiful it was a very very
effective system also I was impressed by
the youth programs that they have
but this wasn't all just in the past
wasn't all just back in the day when
Bernie was a young idealist it's even
when Bernie was an ancient communist
idealist Bernie is still defending
socialist thugs today like Maduro in
Venezuela why have you stopped short of
calling Maduro of Venezuela a dictator
well he I think it's it's fair to say
that the last election was undemocratic
but there are still democratic
operations taking place in that country
and it's not just on foreign policy
Bernie Sanders I remember this more
clearly than any other aspect of his
2016 campaign he was asked a question
about consumer choice and and Bernie
decided right here at home to emphasize
what his style of socialism means he
decided to pull up one of the worst
scourge us facing the American people
that we have too many deodorants to
choose from Bernie Sanders said he goes
to the supermarket and he saw so many
different types of deodorant and that
filled him with rage because consumers
should not be able to choose that many
different types of deodorant the end of
the day you know
necessarily neither choice of 23
underarm spray do horns or 18 different
pairs of sneakers when children are
hungry I have visited Cuba I've been
inside the stores in Cuba they don't
have a lot of different kinds of
deodorant in Cuba they don't have a lot
of anything in Cuba it's all the same
government approved brand it's pretty
low quality its Brio low quality because
consumers don't have a choice it is not
an exaggeration to say that that Cuban
style communist vision is Bernie
Sanders's vision for America he said it
himself not 40 years ago 30 years ago 20
years ago he said it the last time he
ran for president and he believes it
today all awful two visions of America
thriving flourishing make America great
again our best days lie ahead it's the
State of the Union vision the Trump
vision socialism is the other vision in
another State of the Union address
President Trump said America will never
be a socialist country I've got a big
round of applause I hope that's true
there are signs that young people are
moving towards socialism the good the
good news about that the silver lining
is that most of the people who say that
don't even know what socialism is
conservatives go wrong because we argue
against socialism from a purely economic
perspective and particularly from
utility often you'll hear socialism
doesn't work
socialism destroys the economy socialism
is inefficient it's not the best way to
allocate different goods in the economy
yeah that's all true but the real
problem with socialism is not just that
it's inefficient you know and you can't
buy as much stuff with socialism the
real problem is socialism is that it is
evil it's evil it's wicked it's inhuman
it's wrong it's vicious
that's how you got to argue against
socialism nobody cares if your taxes are
gonna be a little bit higher and you
can't buy as many cheap plastic goods
from China that's not the argument
that's not going to resonate with
anybody the argument against socialism
is that it is evil when you speak in
those kind of moral terms becomes clear
and you can look at it in the history of
Western religion
pope leo xiii one of the great popes
when socialism was getting really
popular back hundred hundred twenty
years ago pope leo xiii wrote a couple
people and cyclical z-- about this he
referred to socialism not as inefficient
and you can you know buy as many things
he referred to it as a plague a pest a
wicked confederacy stealing the very
gospel itself to advance the depraved
teachings of the socialists depraved he
said that it was and empathically unjust
he warned people he said how intolerable
and hateful is slavery
citizens would be subjected to under
socialism he said that for all believing
christians socialism must be utterly
rejected that it quote is directly
contrary to the natural rights of
mankind that it would it be in reality
the leveling down of all to a like
condition of misery and degradation that
is the problem with socialism and it
wasn't just a hundred or one hundred
twenty years ago that that we heard this
from people we heard it from pope john
paul ii one of the guys who took down
communism one of the great great men of
the twentieth century he said on the
utilitarian argument he said on the
level of individual nations and of
international relations the free market
is the most efficient instrument for
utilizing resources and effectively
responding to needs then he goes on to
say the fundamental error of socialism
is anthropological in nature not that
its economic in nature not that it's
just not that efficient that it actually
has to do with who we are as humans he
goes on socialism considers the
individual person simply as an element a
molecule within the social organism so
that the good of the individual is
completely subordinated to the
functioning of the socio-economic
mechanism and that is evil that is
wicked that is wrong that is how we've
got to talk about socialism people are
pulled by moral arguments the left is
always trying to make moral arguments
and it's their moral arguments are
completely incoherent I saw one tonight
when President Trump was speaking about
the State of the Union
I saw one argument that said on Twitter
the guy said a lot of late term
abortions saves many lives I thought
that that is the least coherent
statement I've ever late term abortion
by definition ends lives it ends every
life that it touches late but that's the
kind of argument they make they say we
have to kill all those babies to save
people I mean it's like out of 1984 it's
George Orwell war is peace freedom is
slavery ignorance is strength late term
abortion saves many lives the completely
false deceptive arguments but they are
moral arguments they're making the
argument from the perspective socialism
is going to save people socialism is
going to make people happier it's going
to make people more fulfilled has it
that's never been true anywhere in
history
socialism is going to fulfill man's
promise never has its destroyed man's
promise because it fundamentally
misunderstands human nature those are
the arguments that we have to make I
think President Trump has begun to make
those arguments fairly well we now need
to make them two because the Trump heir
has been great the state of our union is
strong when you look forward a couple
generations you see Millennials Gen Z
leaning pretty left-wing leaning into
socialism and if we want to keep the
good times going and I think that our
best lays the best days could lie ahead
but if we want to keep those good times
going we need to make clear that stark
difference
now speaking of morality I've got to
call out Elizabeth Warren for another
another lie it's not just enough to
point out why the one vision is immoral
we also need to point out how the left
doesn't even live up to their own
standards you know Elizabeth Warren
look there if all we did was focus on
the lies that Elizabeth Warren tells on
this show we would never be able to talk
about anything else
but Elizabeth Warren was just getting
off a plane so that she could go
campaign and
she got caught she got caught with her
hand in the cookie jar she recently
answered a question from a reporter
about the environmental impact of her
career in her campaign she said quote so
I've mostly been flying commercial but
we've been trying to look at other ways
that we can reduce our carbon footprint
that's everything from the car we drive
up and down blah blah but we're trying
to reduce our footprint just take a
little listen to this I will narrate you
through this little clip of Elizabeth
Warren she gets off of this private
airplane and there's a reporter there
filming taking pictures and was born
gets off no big deal she got some
staffers a driver then you can see Liz
Warren sees the reporter and what does
she do she hides she hides right behind
one of her staffers and whenever the
reporter kind of moves she kind of moves
behind to because she knows her the
camera line is and she doesn't want to
get caught they don't want to get caught
in the their hypocrisy they don't want
to get caught in the incoherence of the
arguments that they're making and it's
our job to point them out Trump did a
great job of that tonight you can you
can make that in a positive way you
don't need to just dunk on people all
the time you don't need to to make it
personal Trump didn't make it personal
at all tonight about himself at least he
didn't make it about this impeachment
farce he didn't make it about how the
Democrats done him wrong he didn't he
just made the positive argument for what
what he was doing why his vision was
better than the other vision it was
terribly effective it was really great
I'll just leave you on this I have to
get to this story before we go this is
from CNN right CNN is reporting on this
public health crisis in a communist
country China this is the coronavirus
scare that is now claiming multiple
lives it seems to have started because
people were eating bat soup something
that I just don't recommend you ever do
everyone's very nervous about this there
have been in some cases in the United
States and in other places so there's a
task force now being assembled by the
White House to deal with this so it
doesn't become a big problem how do you
think CNN covers that CNN covers it
tweeting out quote coronavirus task
force another example of Trump
administration's lack of diversity
that's the big takeaway that the Trump
administration task force to deal with
the scary crazy bat flu that's killing
people has too many white guys on it
that's the problem
I'd like to point out that the Trump
administration task force on this
coronavirus is exactly as racially
diverse as the twenty20 Democratic
presidential field right now but that's
neither here nor there who's counting
the point is when you're looking at the
problems it it doesn't have to be that
complicated
I think people in politics they're
always trying to gain this out how can I
get the advantage how can I position
myself how can I make myself look really
good and look better than that guy it's
kind of a Buddha jej idea right I'm
gonna use these words and a
mealy-mouthed way to pretend like I want
Iowa even though there's no evidence
that I won Iowa yet and how am I gonna
game it over it can be a lot more simple
than that tell the truth do the things
that people want you to do mean what you
say stop making everything about you
just do your job that's what the state
of the union was did beyond all of the
good rhetoric and there was pretty good
rhetoric it wasn't Shakespeare or
anything
it was well-written but beyond all of
that the reason was a good State of the
Union is cuz the guy did what he said he
was going to do rush limbaugh the Regent
Rush Limbaugh is the peerless
broadcaster is because it's just not
about him he just tells the truth as he
sees it he respects his audience it's
it's not that complicated the reason
that this the task force out of the
Trump administration is is a good idea
is because it's going to keep us all
from getting this awful illness who
cares what the people look like on the
task force no one's going to know their
names ever it doesn't matter I mean that
it can be that simple if we just do the
thing I think that's one of the great
lessons of the Trump era there was so
much malaise going into twenty
sixteen you remember eight years of
Obama was so awful Hillary Clinton had a
99% chance of winning the country was
just doomed I mean I just felt bad on
Election Day
I didn't think Trump was gonna win
necessarily the polls looked so bad and
so it's all lost right and then it
wasn't then and the things are looking
really good the state of our union has
never been stronger and and the
president says that our best days could
lie ahead
they absolutely could won't be that
complicated we just have to do those
very basic things we have to lean into
our duty we have to love our country and
we have to try to the regardless of
whether half the country is going to sit
down and yell at us and be so upset we
just do those basic things grow jobs
treat people with dignity don't take
away all of their stuff don't love
America make America great again it's as
simple who knew that it was as simple as
that that's our show we've got a lot
more to get to we'll just have to get to
that tomorrow in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show see you then
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies director Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey supervising producers
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson hair and makeup Jessa
alvera production assistants McKenna
Waters and Ryan love the Michael Noel's
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 on the Matt
Walsh show we're not just discussing
politics we're talking culture faith
family all of the things that are really
important to you so come join the
conversation
you